PRIMARIES OR ADVANCED TO A
RUNOFF.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOT WON A
STATEWIDE OFFICE IN TEXAS IN 24
YEARS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
HITTING THE PAUSE BUTTON TONIGHT
AND WHAT COULD BE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST AND MOST CONSEQUENTIAL
TECHNOLOGY DEAL EVER.
IT INVOLVES AN AMERICAN COMPANY
AND THE ADMINISTRATION'S CONCERN
THAT A HOSTILE FOREIGN TAKEOVER
COULD JEOPARDIZE AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP AND A CRITICAL
INDUSTRY.
CORRESPONDENT JULIAN TURNER
LOOKS AT WHAT IS AT STAKE AND
NOT DEAL.
>> WE WILL STAND UP TO ANY
COUNTRY THAT UNLAWFULLY FORCES
AMERICAN COMPANIES TO TRANSFER
THEIR VALUE TECHNOLOGIES.
>> AS THE WORLD RACE TO DEVELOP
A 5G, A SINGLE TAKEOVER IS
STARTING TO UNDERMINE AMERICA'S
COMPETITIVE EDGE IN THE TECH
SECTOR AND JEOPARDIZES NATIONAL
SECURITY INTEREST.
SAN DIEGO-BASED QUALCOMM IS
CURRENTLY LEADING THE PACK WHEN
IT COMES TO 5G RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
BUT A SINGAPOREAN COMPANY CALLED
BROADCOM IS NOW MAKING A BID TO
ACQUIRE QUALCOMM FOR A
STAGGERING $117 BILLION.
ONE OF THE LARGEST DEALS THE
TECH SECTOR HAS EVER SEEN.
EXPERTS NOW WORN THAT WHERE THE
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AE
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AI
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AA
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AS
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AL
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AA
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AE
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AR
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AI
DEAL TO GO THROUGH, QUALCOMM, AN
TELECOM, WOULD BE FORCED OUT OF
THE 5G RACE, HANDING A VICTORY
TO ITS CHINESE COMPETITORS.
>> AMERICANS THAT SHOULD BE
CONCERNED THAT IF CHINA DOES
THIS, AND FIRST OF ALL, THEY ARE
GOING TO DOMINATE GLOBAL
COMMUNICATIONS OF THE WIRELESS
AREA.
ALSO, THAT THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
SPY ON AMERICANS BECAUSE 5G WILL
CONNECT MANY DEVICES IN YOUR
HOME.
>> 5G TECHNOLOGY ISN'T JUST FOR
YOUR TV OR PHONE.
IT WILL BE USED IN THE FUTURE
FOR SELF-DRIVING CARS, AND
WIRELESS VIRTUAL REALITY.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITTEE ON FOREIGN INVESTMENT
IN THE UNITED STATES'S
INTERVENING TO PUT THE DEAL ON
HOLD FOR ONE MONTH WHILE IT
UNDERTAKES A REVIEW, SAYING,
"ANY OTHER POTENTIAL MERGER
BETWEEN BROADCOM AND QUALCOMM
COULD POSE A RISK TO THE
NATIONAL SECURITY OF THE
UNITED STATES."
SENIOR LAWMAKERS ARE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RISKS.
>> CHINA HAS MADE NO SECRET.
THEORY HAVE A NATIONAL STRATEGY,
THEY'VE ANNOUNCED IT, THEY'VE
IMPLEMENT IT TO VACUUM UP
START-UP TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
AND OTHER COMPANIES THAT PRODUCE
DUAL USE TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS
NATIONAL SECURITY IMPLICATIONS.
>> A FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIAL WHO IS FAMILIAR WITH
QUALCOMM TELLS FOX NEWS THAT
ASSURED THIS DEAL GO THROUGH, IT